[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday on this 20th anniversary of the
attacks of 9 11. the events that
of that day that led to the u.s war in
afghanistan dubbed america's longest war
which only came to an end just last
month the campaign was part of the
so-called war on terror fought not just
in afghanistan but worldwide and one
decorated commander a former head of
special operations was involved in key
developments all along the way cbs news
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herrich spoke with him ahead
of the anniversary
at ground zero
[Music]
and what has become an iconic moment
then president george w bush made a
promise that would soon unleash u.s
military might on al-qaeda and the
these taliban down
will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
how did 9 11 change the course of your
career oh dramatically retired four star
general tony thomas and former head of
special operations has served in
afghanistan almost every year since the
attacks when he got there in december
2001 thomas and his team settled into
bagram air base where they wanted to
raise the american flag but pentagon
leadership told them we aren't staying
we aren't occupying and we aren't nation
building and then we proceeded to do all
the above meanwhile al qaeda leader
osama bin laden quickly slipped through
the rugged mountains of torabora into
neighboring pakistan
and with him the radical ideology that
spawned a network of global terror
franchises
how much of a threat was abu musab
al-zarqawi the leader of al-qaeda in
iraq huge and arguably one that we
didn't discern early on
another example of how the threat
metastasized after 9 11. absolutely yeah
but because that wasn't resident in iraq
when we first got there the mission
prevented another 911 but there were
close calls the 2009 underwear bomb that
nearly brought down a jet over detroit
and the following year a car bomb that
failed to explode in new york's times
square
and the ideology was strong and intent
on conducting additional attacks against
the united states and our allies
ten years into the war on terror thomas
played a key role in the raid that
killed bin laden
general what's it like to walk into the
situation room and brief the president
it's a pretty profound event synced in
electronically with the white house
situation room as then president obama
and his team watched the elite navy
seals clear the target this heavily
fortified compound in a badabad pakistan
well the commander ford in in pakistan
on the satellite radio made the call
forgotten country
geronimo geronimo geronimo which was our
call sign or a code word for we got him
was the death of osama bin laden an
inflection point in the war on terror
it absolutely was so important to get
the leader but we still had a lot of
work left to do three years later in
syria isis terrorists held americans
hostage including journalists and an aid
worker kayla mueller none in the group
would survive
thomas recounts how close special
operators came to freeing them the
keller mueller episode would be the low
point and i think there was one or two
other american hostages that we thought
were being held
we conducted a raid and and discovered
that they had just moved those losses
stay with thomas he shared the story of
a 27-year-old special operations
engineer aaron red butler killed in
afghanistan by a crude bomb but i'll
never forget the mother because as i met
her and expressed my condolences to her
she gripped my hand as if she wasn't
going to let me go and she said general
stay on this and finish it we spoke with
thomas before 13 service members died
while evacuating americans and afghans
from the kabul airport
even then thomas feared the ungoverned
space
we have now
given up an area of prime access and
intelligence in afghanistan
and
we've maybe emboldened some adversaries
and the future will determine how safe
we actually are
only in recent years has the 9 11 story
come full circle for thomas i don't
think i uh physically got to new york
man
what i consider be hallowed ground it's
about the 2014-2015 time frame again
remember just a rush of emotion this is
where where it all began for cbs this
morning saturday katherine herridge
washington
and it's that that mother's concern that
service member's mother's concern is
what you think of now that we are out of
afghanistan so many who gave their lives
and remember it's hard we can say it's
hard to believe it's been 20 years but
for those who lost loved ones it's every
day